du R's done a lot of great work on
nonconvex optimization and tens methods
so thank you thanks uh so uh today I'm
going to talk about some uh recent works
on prole learning of noisy or networks
uh this is Joint work with uh sanie uh
tangu and Andre
uh uh so this is based on two recent
works one has the same title and will
appear in stock and the other is uh
stent
submission uh so before I tell you what
are noisy or networks uh uh let me first
explain why are we interested in
learning noise uh in learning these
networks so uh one idea on learning uh
representation one fairly traditional
idea is to use uh latent variable models
so in latent variable models I will
assume that my data come from some model
with unknown parameters and if I manage
to estimate these unknown parameters uh
they will tell me about the structure in
my data for example in mixure of gions I
want to learn what are the means and
cence for these gions for topic models I
want to learn for each topics uh what
words uh do we use for these topics so
it turns out for many of these uh simple
lat variable models we can learn that
using uh a technique called
tensor DEC composition uh hereby we can
learn what I mean is if you want to
estimate the parameters with accuracy
Epsilon you can do that uh with
polinomial in problem parameter and one
or Epsilon that many samples and uh
running time is also the same
polinomial uh so so we can learn these
simple models but what happens when we
try to generalize uh these results to
slightly more complic ated models like
the nor or networks that I'm going to
Define uh very soon so these more
complicated models are more similar to
uh uh more uh nonlinear versions uh of
uh the traditional models in particular
it is a uh it is very similar to
restricted bman machines so hopefully
understanding these models will tell us
a bit more about why uh deep
representation s are very
useful uh but unfortunately the same
kind of techniques does not apply
immediately uh these problems turns out
to be harder to learn and there are uh
much fewer uh algorithms with the same
kind of
guarantees so uh one separation here is
for all of these uh previous models that
we know how to learn using T3
compositions uh these turn out to be
linear models and for these these models
that we do not know how to learn uh
before uh they are actually nonlinear I
will make this linear versus nonlinear
more precise uh later in my talk so uh
in this talk we will try to see what are
some ideas we can use in order to learn
these nonlinear uh latent variable
models so so what is a noisy or network
well the typical application is as a
intended application is for a disease
symptom networ work so this is a simple
base net uh it's a simple base net
because the graph in the base net is
just a bipartite graph on one side of
the graph we have uh M symptom M
diseases uh so these diseases will be 01
variables and it will be one with some
fixed
probability and then on the other side
of the bipartite graph we have uh n
symptoms and we have an edge between the
disease and the symptom if uh this
disease have some probability of causing
this
symptom so uh when a patient goes into
the hospital of course what we can
observe are these symptoms we do not
directly observe the diseases so the
goal of this network uh is that if we
observe the symptoms of many patients we
would want to learn how many diseases
are there and for each of the disease
what are the subset of symptoms that
this disease might
cause uh so more precisely there are um
diseases uh each disease will be one
with probability row and they are all
independent uh and uh in this uh
bipartite graph we will have edges an
edge means the disease might cause a
symptom and the probability the
probability that the disease C the
symptom is related to the edge weight
and here we will uh use this particular
parameterization which is uh standard in
the literature uh it says if you if the
patient has only one disease uh the
probability that this symptom does not
happen is equal to e to the minus of the
weight so this is uh the weight is
always a positive uh number so this is
always something between zero and
one and uh in the 1990s people have uh
tried to construct these uh disease
symptom networks uh from
expert uh knowledge so one very famous
data set or one very famous Network that
people have constructed is called the
qmr DT Network it has uh 570 diseases uh
roughly 4,000 symptoms and roughly
45,000
edges so uh I haven't explained uh when
a patient have more than one disease
what happens uh what what symptoms
should we observe and that is also why
this uh this model is often called the
noisy or model so let me explain
now so suppose uh the patient have these
two diseases disease one and two and
maybe both of these diseases have 50%
probability of causing this particular
symptom remember this probability is
some related to the edge weight uh so in
this case uh a prior of course there
could be uh different probabilities of
this patient having the symptom but in
the no or network uh the model says uh
the each disease will try to cause this
symptom independently so disease one
will cause this symptom with probability
50% and disease two will cause the same
symptom with prob probability 50% and we
will observe this symptom if at least
one of the diseases have caused the
symptom uh and of course then it's easy
to compute that the probability that we
observe the symptom is just
75% and this is called noisy or because
the noisy part refers to each uh disease
causing these symptoms uh randomly and
the or part means once we uh have the
diseases caused by all sorry once we
have the symptoms caused by all the
diseases uh the final observation is a
un or an or of all of these
symptoms uh we can of course uh
formalize this uh even when you have uh
even when the patient have more than two
uh diseases and we can write uh the
conditional probability of not having a
symptom fairly suly as a product of
these exponential
functions so uh for these models what we
can do is uh we uh in the first work we
give a polinomial Time algorithm that
can recover this W the weight The Edge
weights between diseases and symptoms uh
with a relative Arrow row Time s root m
in Alto arrow in each column remember
each uh we we formalize this Matrix W in
the sense that each column correspond on
to a disease so what this is saying is
for each disease we can uh fairly
accurately recover all the symptoms that
it uh will cause and in order to
interpret this uh let's first recall
that row is the probability that uh the
patient have one particular disease so
we should expect row to be something
small we we usually expect row to be a
constant over M if row is anything
larger than that that then the patient
has more a super constant number of
diseases and that's very
unfortunate uh so so we always think row
is a constant over M and in this case
the relative arrow is just one over
square root M so it it is fairly small
and also in this uh first result we
don't have any requirement on the
structure of the disease symptom Network
it doesn't have to be very sparse or
have some special
properties uh the problem with the first
uh result is that uh it is a polinomial
time but the polinomial is fairly large
uh so in the next uh result we show that
if the network has some additional nice
property if it has some nice
combinatorial structure which is true
for the qmr DT Network then we give a
new algorithm that can recover this
weight Matrix with accuracy Epsilon in
polinomial number of samples and running
time uh the structure the combinatorial
structure that we use is very similar to
uh previous works by uh uni Hoin and
David sok uh but our algorithm is much
faster and can run on for example
synthetic examples for the qmr DT
Network um so on these synthetic data we
can recover uh roughly 300 diseases out
of the
570 um okay so throughout this talk I
will try to uh make a comparison between
topic models and noisy or uh so a lot of
our algorithms are inspired by the
algorithms from topic models uh so I
will expl explain uh what are those
algorithms and what we need to do in
order to uh apply similar algorithms to
the noisy or model so let's first uh
quickly recap that a top in a topic
model uh we want to learn the topics
from a lot of documents
so uh a topic is just a distribution
over words similarly in the noisy or
Model A disease is like a topic and a
symptom is like a word and here a
disease is just defined to be a set of
symptoms um and of course in topic
models we allow a document to have
multiple topics and in that case the
words in this document will just come
from a mixture
distribution uh in the noisy or model we
also allow a patient to have multiple
diseases in that case the symptoms are
from the union of
symptoms uh the goal of topic model is
given a lot of documents we want to
automatically find all of these topics
and the goal of noisy or network is uh
if we observe the symptoms of a lot of
patients we would like to find out this
graph structure we want to find uh for
each disease what symptoms will this
disease cause
uh so for topic models there are many
algorithms with proof guarantees but
unfortunately for noisy or uh there are
much fewer algorithms so why are topic
models much easier to learn in this
sense uh as I uh mentioned in the first
slide uh that's likely to be because
topic models are linear but noisy or is
not linear uh let me make that more
precise and uh for simp it let's look at
a a case when the document just have uh
just has two topics which corresponds to
a patient with two diseases in the noisy
or
network so in this case for topic model
if you want to generate the words from
this document what happens is maybe you
sample some fraction of the words from
topic one you will sample some other
fraction of words from topic two right
and uh similarly in the no or network
you will generate uh symptoms uh
independently from disease one and
disease 2 so up to here everything still
looks very similar but uh what's
different is the in the topic modeling
case the final document is just a
collection of all of these words
generating generated from both of these
topics um so if a word can be generated
from both topic one and topic two it
will just appear more
often uh but for the disease uh symptom
Network the final symptom is a un of the
two sets so say if I have two diseases
that both will cause say headache then
my symptom is still just headache I I
cannot say quantitatively that I feel
twice as pain as uh I I had so so this
um so for the disease symptom Network
the final symptom is just Union and it
is a non linear operation mathematically
what this means is if we take the
expectation of this document is going to
be a linear combination of the topics on
the other hand if we take the
expectation of the symptom of a patient
then it is going to be a nonlinear
expression uh were there some
question question for the topic model
after learning uh the topic model you
you don't know the name of the topic so
after learn the noisy model do you know
the the name of the disease oh that's a
good question so uh yeah it's again
similar to topic models once you learn
the diseases you also don't know the
name of the disease uh is useful you
know here is a disease but you don't
know the name of the
disease uh well I I guess uh the name of
the disease is just a word right what we
really want to know is how to to treat
this disease and how to uh like what to
do if you
diagn if you know the patient have this
disease and that can be formalized as a
uh Downstream learning application and
presumably if you are able to learn this
model that's going to be useful if
there's no name you can call it wrong
speci yes you would ask an expert right
of course uh yeah sometimes you might
discover new dis
yeah if you discover something that
people already know hopefully an expert
will tell you and if you discover new
things then it requires a new name
anyways uh more question so in your real
data set how often is it the case that
patients have multiple diseases and if
it if they do have multiple diseases
that they actually have the same
symptoms the reason I ask is if usually
patients have one or if they have
multiple that fairly different then
isn't this approximately linear and not
exactly uh oh right so so the the prior
of this qmr DT data set the probability
of the disease is actually not that low
so uh the patient usually have a not
just one disease but a a fewer diseases
uh um they're including things like high
blood pressure as a disease yeah
patients will have five not one right so
yeah so these are not like really major
diseases like if you have for those of
course if you have if a patient have
five that's very bad but these things
are and the is people who end up in the
hospital so usually they discover
wouldn't high blood pressure be a
symptom not a
disease
there I mean the the whole the whole
data set is uh like anonymized like it
doesn't have the names of diseases and
symptoms so we don't really know what
are these diseases and symptoms but but
there was a literature which said that
actually they are five four five disease
for paent oh yes so so that number we do
know yes uh question so let's say you
have five distinct diseases nameless
diseases in your trading data how would
you discover new diseases would you just
add extra nodes to your network and hold
that to discover new diseases uh well
we'll see uh so so uh so
again it is similar to uh the topic
model in topic model in in practice how
do you know how many topics are there
that's also not very clear but in theory
the number of topics is going to be
similar to the rank of a particular
Matrix and here you as you will soon see
something very similar is going to
happen and of course we can always try
to First find the most significant
diseases and then try to find other
ones
dises you can think of it as causes it's
it's basically a causal model you want
to know what is the number of causes and
what are the symptoms maybe causes
rather than diseases
right yeah so uh that's right it has
this model has old history yeah
exactly yeah so so so how do we learn
these nonlinear models well a natural
idea is since I know how to learn these
linear models maybe in order to learn
these nonlinear models we will just try
to find a way to linearize the model so
how do I linearize the model well uh uh
so one way you can do is to use the
pointwise M
information uh and pointwise M
information is a measure uh on the
correlation between random variables
here we Define a PMI Matrix the 's in
will be just the pointwise mutal
information between not having disease I
and not having disease J uh PMI for X
and Y is just defined to be the log of
the ratio between the probability that
both of them happens divided by the
probability that uh they uh each of them
happen
individually so uh in intuitively if the
PMI between two uh random variables is
larger than zero it means these two
variables are positively correlated and
if it's smaller than zero then these two
variables are negatively correlated and
it's zero if they are not correlated at
all
um using this idea um it's easy to see
that if two symptoms I and J share a
disease so there is a disease that will
cause that has probability to cause both
of these symptoms then they should be
positively
correlated and in that case the PMI will
be larger than zero
if these two if symptoms I and J just do
not share any disease then according to
this uh model uh these two symptoms are
completely independent and pii will be
equal to zero so intuitiv Fe this PMI
will give you some intuition about the
the graph structure and turns out you
can actually compute this pii Matrix
according to the parameters uh the final
result is uh looks like here a uh uh a
low rank Matrix row times uh some of
these rank one components plus higher
old terms uh that might be high rank but
they are much smaller compared to the
first term so PMI Matrix is
approximately this uh low rank Matrix uh
the rank of this P PMI Matrix is roughly
the number of diseases in this
network um and it's also very easy to
prove this claim the idea is you will
just use Tailor's expansion on the log
log of 1 plus X is roughly X so that's
how you get that um and uh these higher
order terms of course corresponds to the
higher order terms in the tailored
expansion uh so intuitively what this is
saying is if we apply the log
transformation it linearizes the product
uh remember the the condition the
products here the probabilities here are
written as a product uh of the
probability
um
so oh oh right so the question was what
is f f
is what is Right m is the number of uh
diseases and F is a matrix that's
closely related to the edge weights that
we are trying to
learn um so we uh we will also generally
generalize this idea to compute three
wise uh correlations between the
symptoms
so and once we compute the three wise
correlation between the symptoms we will
be able to find apmi tensor so the three
wise uh PMI for symptoms IJ and K is
again of a similar expression is again
the log of some ratio of uh
probabilities uh I will not really
explain how to get this but intuitively
if we compute this value for all three
uh toppos of symptoms we will get a n by
n byn tensor where n is the number of
symptoms uh this tensor will measure the
three wise correlation between the
symptoms and uh the reason this formula
looks like this is that's that it is
very uh similar to the inclusion
exclusion
formula uh using the same uh idea we can
prove a very similar claim for the PMI
tensor and it turns out that the PMI
tensor is very again very close to a low
rank tensor it is the sum of these rank
one
components
uh so for the PMI tensor we also have
the similar higher order terms as we had
for the PMI Matrix so there are some
terms that are row Square Times other
things and we will call these higher
order terms systematic errow because
these are things that happens because
the linearization is not perfect these
systematic error terms will not go to
zero even if you take infinite many
samples okay so now uh let's recall how
uh were we able to learn uh topic models
using tensor decomposition so the idea
there is if you can compute the word
word correlation Matrix it turns out
that will be a low rank Matrix you can
then also compute the word word word the
three wise correlation tensor and you
can show that again is a low rank tensor
using these two pieces of information uh
we can apply a tensor decomposition
algorithm and that will give us the
topic
Matrix so we will try to use the same
approach for learning noise or network
so uh how do we do that well we the hope
is we have the PMI Matrix which is
approximately low rank uh like this we
have the PMI tensor which is again
approximately low rank so if we apply
tensor decomposition we should recover
these component FK and FK is directly
related to the parameters we want to
learn but uh the challenge here is we
actually do not have these exact PMI
Matrix and or or this exact low rank
Matrix and this exact low rank tensor uh
our tensor has this systematic error
term that do not go to zero even if you
take infinite number of samples so we uh
the real problem is we need to um have a
way to handle systematic error
carefully uh for Simplicity in this talk
I'll only talk about how to do that for
the PMI
Matrix um so let's first look at what
are these higher order terms turns out
the higher order term also looks like uh
a low rank Matrix it will the second not
term is like row Square time GG
transpose where G is a Matrix that's
actually very similar to
F okay so so now from this PMI Matrix
usually what we want to get is to find
the column span of this Matrix
F uh how do we do that well this is a
fairly typical uh Matrix perturbation
scenario right we have this PMI Matrix
which we think is similar to row FF
transpose we have some noise terms so I
just want to say even after after adding
these noise terms the span of the top
singular vectors of the PMI Matrix is
still close to the span of The Columns
of F and there are of course many
standard Matrix perturbation theorems
like Davis Kahan or wedding theorem but
uh unfortunately these theorems are not
strong enough um in our uh model they
will actually uh give you a recovery
error of row times m uh and remember uh
this is not a very interesting Bond
because row was like five time M and row
M is even larger than one so the result
is uh very uh is not accurate the main
problem here is actually because both of
these two matrices f and g uh they are
not very well conditioned the condition
number for these two matrices are bad
and if you take the largest singular
value of G and divide by the smallest
singular value of f that's going to be
very
problematic okay so how do we fix this
well the key observation here is f and g
are not two arbitrary matrices G is not
a arbitrary perturbation G is actually
very similar to
F uh here especially if you assume W if
if you think W is somewhat small then G
is like 2 * F of course W is not that
small but the same intuition applies so
intuition is I have this Matrix f it has
different singular directions maybe it
is more robust or more tolerant to
perturbation on the large singular
directions uh what do I mean by that so
here are the two cases uh so the uh the
blue ellipsoid that correspond to the
singular directions of f the yellow
corresponds to the singular directions
of G and in these two cases in the first
case the large largest singular value of
G is aligned with the smallest singular
value of F and in this case the singular
directions of G is more aligned with the
singular directions of f right so one
would expect that in this case we should
have a larger perturbation because uh G
tried to perturb the small Direction
Which is less robust and in this case we
should have much smaller
perturbation but existing uh theorems
like the ones I mentioned before they
will not differentiate between these two
cases because what they care about is
just what is the spectral Norm of G
which is just this AIS uh and what is
the smaller singular value of f which is
just this axis so traditional theorems
will not work here and we need a new uh
Matrix perturbation
LMA uh so what we are able to prove is
that uh the recovery eror uh The Matrix
perturbation uh is bonded by row times
this ratio here which we Define to be
top so what is this ratio well it turns
out if you forget about FF transpose
here then the denominator is just the
sigma mean of FF transpose so that
recovers the previous Bon but now we are
adding FF transpose what that allows us
to do is to say in the directions where
f is large we can allow G to also be
large uh in turns out this will
significantly reduce this parameter tow
for qmr DT this tow is smaller than
six uh as opposed to a few hundred for
the previous case and under some
probabilistic assumptions on the disease
uh symptom Network we can show this is
proly a small constant uh independent of
the dimension of the model so using this
idea uh we can show that even if you
just look at the PMI Matrix uh it
suffices to get a good approximation for
the span of
f uh this is not done yet because we
need to generalize this idea to
asymmetric matrices and even to tensors
uh but uh this is done in paper but I
will not talk about it for this
talk okay just a very quick summary we
in the first part the idea is we can use
uh nonlinear Transformations like PMI to
approximately linearize this kind of a
log linear model and then uh this will
introduce some systematic bias but we
can use better Matrix or tensor
perturbation results to handle these
systematic
errors uh the challenge here is in order
to estimate the P tensor you actually
need a lot of samples and and it's more
than what we can even simulate let Al
along what um real data will have so in
the next part I will just briefly talk
about how to use structure of the
disease symptom graph to get a faster
algorithm so this faster algorithm is
again inspired by some works of topic
models uh so this is based on the idea
of anchor words so again so we compare
uh topic models and uh noisy or networks
uh in this Matrix the RADS correspond to
words or symptoms so columns corresponds
to uh topics or diseases
and we will say a uh symptom is an
anchor symptom if it appears in only one
disease so this symptom is specific to
one disease it will not be caused by any
other disease uh similarly of course an
anchor word is just a word that appear
in only one topic uh as an example the
second row here uh correspond to a
anchor symptom or a anchor word because
it has only one nonzero entry uh the
last row here is not an anchor symptom
or anchor word because it has two
non-zero
entries so for topic models we know
there are there are very efficient
algorithms that can learn the topic
models if all the topics have Anor words
so it's natural to think maybe we can
use the same idea to learn the noisy or
networks because we also have the PMI
Matrix which is a linearized version
unfortunately for qmr DT not all
diseases have uncor symptoms so applying
this algorithm immediately will not work
for qmr DT so what can we hope for uh so
the the graph structure might look like
this and you can see here are two anchor
symptoms and there are two corresponding
diseases and there are these diseases
that do not have any Anor
symptoms so the idea is okay maybe these
uh uh these diseases already have anchor
symptoms maybe we can learn them first
and then we can remove
them what happens if we do that well if
we remove those two diseases these two
symptoms which were not unor before now
they become unor symptoms and now all
the remaining diseases actually have uh
unur
symptoms so uh of course uh this is just
a very simple example in general we can
repeat this procedure T times and think
of t as a small constant uh tal to 7
suffices for the qmr DT data set uh tal
to 7 actually suffices for something
stronger that I Define here uh so it
actually we do not only guarantee that
each disease have one anchor symptom we
actually guarantee that in this
recursive procedure each disease will
have at least two Anker
symptoms uh so this is also the same
assumption that's made by previous work
uh the previous Works uh the first work
require uh gives an algorithm to learn
the model if the graph structure is
known if I know where there's an edge
and where there's no Edge in the second
work uh this is relaxed but the graph
needs to satisfy a different condition
called quartet
learnable uh our result uh gives a
faster algorithm compared to these two
uh works but uh unfortunately for all
these three works the sample complexity
depend uh exponentially on
T um so the only thing we can hope for
is maybe you can learn the diseases in
the first few layers uh unless you have
very large number of Sy uh of uh
patients it will be hard to learn uh a
large number of uh
layers so so what's our algorithm we
actually reduce the noisy or problem to
a symmetric non-active Matrix
factorization problem recall the PMI
Matrix is close to this low rank Matrix
uh row times FF transpose and F is a
non- negative Matrix because it's inas
are 1 minus E to the minus W K and W is
a non-active uh Matrix itself so all the
interest in F are between 0 one and this
is a symmetric non-active Matrix
factorization problem
similar to before we need to worry about
the higher order terms but uh in this
talk I'm going to ignore that and say we
focus on the exact non-active Matrix
factorization
problem uh so how do we do that under
the sequential to Anchor condition well
the condition kind of question oh yes so
the condition kind of uh tells you what
kind of algorithms you want right uh the
condition says you can repeatedly find
these uncor words and remove the the
disease diseases and you will find more
anchor symptoms so in each step we will
just try to find all the anchor symptoms
we will try to learn the diseases which
at least two anchors and then we will
remove these diseases from the graph and
from the PMI
Matrix uh so uh so let's look at the
detailed steps of this algorithm so the
first problem is how do we find the
enchor symptoms uh so the idea is fairly
simple it's based on two observations
the first observation is if I have these
two anchor symptoms that corresponds to
the same disease then just by matrix
multiplication the corresponding row
here the the two corresponding rows here
are both uh just a constant multiplied
with this row here so these two rows are
actually equal up to a uh multiplicative
Factor
so in this case uh these rows are
duplicates so if you can find duplicates
they are very likely to be enors for the
same disease question would it be
possible if ination like when is is like
around
yes uh right so the question is whether
in some interation you will not be able
to find uh Anker words uh for the qmr DT
we have the ground truth graph so we we
indeed check that uh seven layers is
enough and you never run out of anchors
but of course in general it is
definitely possible that the algorithm
might fail at certain
stage um so the second observation here
is that uh is based on the fact that
this is asymmetric Matrix uh
factorization so if I know these four
entries are not non-
negative then that means these four
entri are also non- negative so I can so
which means all of these uh Square uh uh
green squares should belong to my
component that it should belong to this
Vector alter product with this Vector so
I can just try to subtract that and if I
find anything that became negative that
means uh what I had before was not
correct
uh so it turns out if you just use these
two observations uh it suffices to uh
correctly identify all the anchor words
for the qmr DT graph and the second
observation very crucially uses the
symmetric and non-active uh nature of
the problem so once we identify these
uncor symptoms uh finding the disease is
much simpler because we already know
that this disease is is just a multiple
of this row here and we only need to
know the coefficient in order to find
the coefficient we can just look at the
ij's entry and it is equal to row times
the two entries here so if you
substitute this in the right hand side
will be a function of Lambda and we can
just solve for Lambda so we can find the
scaling just by observing this entry
here um
and once you find the scaling of course
we can just uh remove DP by subtracting
uh the this column alter product with
itself from the PMI
Matrix uh so this is shortly how the
algorithm Works uh we have done some
synthetic experiments uh so we do not
have real patient data so what we do
here is we use the ground Chu uh data
set to generate a large number of
samples and try to run the
algorithm uh there are this Top Line is
the total number of diseases and uh blue
line is what happens if we compute the
infinite uh data limit and in that case
indeed the algorithm will be able to
find all the diseases but in practice uh
even if you have uh 100 million samples
the algorithm can only find the the
algorithm is very robust in the first
layer uh with a relative Arrow .01 but
even for the second layer it can it
already is a little bit worse than the
infinite sample regime and the third
layer completely fails because the noise
uh multip uh multiply uh in each
layer so there are still many open
problems here so of course the even the
better algorithm we have is still not
very practical it especially in terms of
sample complexity so we would want to to
improve that uh also we would want to
understand why does the qmr DT Network
have this uh sequential uncor condition
uh is there a good generative model for
these kind of networks and finally uh
our ultimate goal is by uh looking at
these nonlinear models we hope to learn
more nonlinear models such as restricted
bman machines or de Bel networks uh
thanks
question